hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round six of the 2020
Tata Steel masters edition it's Daniel
dooba vs. Vladislav artemyev and we've
already covered a game that Artemyev
lost the holidays of fallujah hope I
pronounced it correctly this time as
some of you sent me the way to pronounce
it it's furious Joe so apparently both
the Z and the J so thanks for that but
yeah he already lost the game to Veeru
John are playing that variation of the
caro-kann and now he will employ the
same variation against dubov so let's
see how that works out
dubov opens with E for now we have c6
the caro-kann defense d4 d5 and E 5 the
advanced variation of the caro-kann
Bishop to f5 developing the lights
worship before closing the cage and the
now age for the adobo goes for the tall
variation the same as Fallujah did so h5
and now c4 so everything the same as in
that game east six nights to c3 and here
our teammate went to Knight to e7
against future but here he goes Bishop
to e7 saying that okay I'm pretty sure
you've checked the game I played against
future so let's just deviate here
dubov continued seek after Sundy 5c
capture Sun d5 and now Bishop to d3
offering a trade of light square bishop
the bishop captures we have Queen
captures and now Knight to c6 continuing
development we have Knight to f3 and now
Knight to h6 which is often the way you
want to go when White has the advanced
EEP on preventing normal development or
of your Knights so pushing the H pawn
makes sense when developing this night
this way but dubov decides to give up
the dark square Bishop to prevent the
knight from jumping over to f5 the
knight would be a really strong piece on
f5 since the h-bomb prevents g4 so you
will not be able to kick away the night
from there and there will be a lot of
pressure towards the d4 pawn so Bishop
characters on h6 we have route
characters on h6 and now there is one in
the game in the database where g3 was
played but here Duggal goes for Luke to
c1 and it is as of move 12 that we have
a completely
new game so Artemyev continuous kinked
faith he wants to play g6 bring the King
over at the g7 and then bring the route
back to h8 and bring the rook into the
game this way so this is the way he will
now Castle artificially g3 by dubov we
have g6 continuing with the plan we have
castles and the king to g7 and now
Knight to a4 now aduba wants to grab
hold of the c5 square and you cannot
fermented the night since the knight
would Hank so we have worked the h8 and
now Knight the c5 of course our team if
captures the knight it's it's a very
strong piece so Bishop captures we have
rook captures and c5 and now Queen to d7
developing the queen preparing for the
rook to enter the game we have rook F 2
c1 now nicely doubling up on the C file
and rook h2c 8 so the rook is now into
the game and the artificial castling has
been completed and here we have Queen to
c3 and there was a lot of questions in
the chat whether this is the aliens none
the the weapon that aria him used in his
game against our own nimzowitsch in 1930
and it should not be the aliens guns so
I didn't gun if is if it's a Queen rook
rook battery so if the rook was here
regardless of the fact that it would be
captured but this is against grant so
that this Queen this rook Queen rooks
and which is not aliens gun or maybe it
is maybe someone decided that any
battery including two rooks in the Queen
is a hands gun but in the original it's
actually Queen rook rook so we have a
five
now preventing b4 so a3 dubov prepares
before and now a four now if you play it
then just a character son b3 and Poisson
and here Knights the e1 and from Iman
the knight can go to some very
attractive squares you can go to G to
fall by e3 you can go to f4 you can go
to back to f3 and then to g5 you can go
to d3 2 B 4 so a lot of very interesting
options for the white knight and here
the problem for black
you kinda don't want to have this or all
this pressure along the C file the
problem is you cannot trade with Knight
to e7 because of rook to c7 and you're
just gonna give a white a lot of
activity so if you trade white just gets
the Queen all the way up there and then
if trades then the a rook takes their
place and if you move the Queen Queen d8
then white can just continue his plan
and bring in the night into the game and
the black is basically without a move so
after this night that you wanna move we
have Queen to e7 a winning moves are
waiting to see what what do bo will do
and here Du Bois goes back Knight to f3
and he decides to go for a different
plan his plan is now he's gonna put the
Knight to g5 and the knight will be an
excellent piece there you cannot kick it
away there is no H pawn the EH one is
already advanced if you push this then
he just opened up the position so he
wants to bring the Knight to g5 he wants
to move the Queen ah maybe bring it to
f4 at some point and put pressure on f7
and also he's considering a nice rook
cliff to rook the C 3 followed by rook
to f3 that put even more pressure on the
f7 pawn so Queen to d7 Artemyev just
wait and now King 2gq improving the
position of the King Artemyev already
announced that he will he will just wait
and see what happens
we have rooked the c7 preparing to
double rooks and the C file maybe then
it will be easier to trade it off and
now Queen back to c2 not allowing this
rook to enter the game because the pawn
on a4 would hang so Queen back to d8 and
now Queen to d1 still keeping an eye on
the pawn here while making it a
possibility for rook the c3 fall by rook
to f3 for this very nice rook lift so
here we have looked a d7 and now Knight
to g5 and the knight cannot be kicked
away from there it's just a beautiful
piece so what do you play here well you
could you could just wait and see what
happens with something like rook to c7
but then like we said the plan is to
bring the roof to c3 to f3 pressure f7
bring the Queen to d3 to F sorry to d2
to f4 and then also you'll have a rook
Queen and night all piling up on F sub
one of the one of the ideas so here
while you could wait for that to happen
our Timmy goes for a more active
approach you place the rook the a6
probably route b6 the b3 is an idea to
not only activate the rook but also to
counter White's rook influence along the
third-ranked
and here the ado goes for for a cup of
Blanca move I would say a couple of
always played a g4 in in any position
you name it so here g4 now everything is
uh you know paralyzed on the Queen side
the centre cannot move and here he wants
to bust open the Kings side so if you
capture of course Queen captures h5 is
coming it's just a very hard position to
play for black so here instead
Queen to h8 by artemiev and now Queen to
f3 putting pressure on f7 okay for the
moment it's protected but also Queen to
f6 could be dangerous in some variations
so here look the b6 and this is a bit
too much for for artemyev as he wants to
bring the rook over to b3 but it seems
just a bit too dangerous or allowing
rook to a5 because then Queen f6 check
is coming you're gonna have a lot of
problems here if you allow rook to a 5
to a 8 but you know you have to play
something so better than rook to b6 was
just a waiting move or just bring the
route back rook to e8 but then you just
have to admit that your previous plan
wasn't really great now there is a
saying that says you know a bad plan is
better than no plan at all this is one
of this is an exception here this no
plan is better than this plan it's
better to just bring the rook back so
here if Queen to f6 check you can just
bring the King back and yes it's it's
very passive but you know after Queen to
f4
why doesn't what doesn't have a threat
so now the game continues and perhaps
black will find the new way but like I
said are timid went for rook to b6 and
now we have G captures on h5 you could
have gone for rook to a5 right away it
puts pressure on the a for pawn but
dubov says ok there's time for that so G
CalPERS on h5 Queen captures on h5 and
now Queen to f6 with check
we have King if you go to h6 then
Knights and capture on f7 very
unpleasant so King to g8 not allowing
ideas like that and now looked a five
and now there's there's a problem how do
you prevent rook to eight check you
cannot go roof to d8 so one way you
could do it the roof to date is
impossible because of Queen captures on
f7 but you could play rook to a6 but
that just bad that just I mean you just
capture capture and you win the night
here so that just loses so after a roof
day five we have Queen to g4 check King
to f1 and now like I said you could try
this and hope that there is some sort of
a perpetual let's say captures captures
captures and then okay you do get Queen
d1 check King G - you can go back Queens
you for checking h2 Queen captures on h4
check
unfortunately for for black and Knight
to h3 is here and all of the squares are
covered also the the Queen trade is
hanging so you don't really have a good
good move here
you still can't block the eight rook c8
check Fallbrook erupt h8 mate is coming
after the King moves to h7 so here you
would have to trade Queens but this is a
pointless end game to play of course
white would be completely winning here
so instead they're our team we've tried
Knight to d8 but still it doesn't work
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the finishing move do both
played while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations and finding
such such a nice move and it is in fact
the only winning move so you know feel
good about yourself if you found it and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
show still its rook to e8 as the knight
is threatened and dat there's no defense
against rook captures and e8 and that's
just it so whatever you play doesn't
really matter you have to make a move
although there are no good moves like
Ruby 3 is is instant mate check captures
and then just captures on f7 fall by
Queen to h7 mate and if you try
something like Queen to f5 to try and
trade Queen's still just rope captures
here rook captures Queen captures King
moves and now you can either just
capture yet another rook or even go rook
and now there's no defense against mate
so there's also that buddy I have to
look to eight of course a lot this lever
Timmy resigned at the game and an
excellent victory for Daniel dubov who
repeated the the line Ferruccio played
against Artemyev and it will be
interesting to see if if Artemia will
try to employ it one more time in this
tournament I'm pretty sure he will but
you know if he enjoys it you know it
does bring a lot of play for both sides
so the games are interesting so I
welcome that it's but but you know if he
feels you know he wants to fight then
then he should fight and I've also
prepared the standings after round six
so here they are
Wesley so and otherwise of fallujah
still in the lead with four out of six
followed by three and a half pointers
Fabiano karana jordan van forest and
daniel do both now after achieving this
victory with three points Jeffrey's
young magnus carlsen young Christophe
Duda Irish want an an and an inch giri
and Vladislav Artemyev Duda and cross
and still doing the Giri out of six game
all six games run well Giri himself only
four draws and one loss and one win
followed by an Akita fatigue of you
young ye and with one point still with
one point of Vladislav Kovalev last
year's winner of the challengers edition
he can't seem to catch a break but yeah
yeah that's you know chess chess is
ruthless so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Martin more Scott's Terry crystal de gwl
and Kevin Hume for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel we still have at least one beam at
the cover from the Women's World Chess
Championship and of course checking up
on your wonderful suggestion and when
there's a rest day and when I got manage
more time we are continuing the morphe
saga as well so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day